Our question asks us, how many
toothpicks will be needed to
form the 50th figure
in this sequence?
So let's look at
this sequence.
So the first figure in our
sequence-- they look like
little houses-- how many
toothpicks are here?
We have one, two, three, four,
five, six toothpicks.
So our first object here, or
our first figure, has six
toothpicks.
How many do we have in
our second figure?
Well we're going to have
these six that we had
in the first, right?
This is the first figure,
right here.
Let me just trace it.
That's the first figure,
right there.
And then how many
new toothpicks
are we going to have?
We have one, two, three,
four, five.
So we have six plus
another five.
So we have the six in the
original one, plus another
five, which is equal
to 11 toothpicks.
Now what happens in this third
object, or this third little
toothpick house looking
drawing thing?
So we have our figure
from the two houses.
So we have those right there.
This is the exact same
thing that we had
as our second object.
So that's that right there.
And how many more do we have?
Well it's going to be
the same thing.
We've just added on this other
extension to our house.
You can view it that way.
So we have one, two,
three, four, five.
So it looks like every time we
go down this sequence, or we
add a new term to the sequence,
or a new object to
the sequence, we're adding
five toothpicks.
So here, we're going
to have 11 plus 5.
There's 11 toothpicks in this
part of it, and then we
have another 5.
11 plus 5, which is 16.
Same thing over here.
We have 16 in this part
of the drawing.
That part of the drawing is
going to be 16 toothpicks, if
you draw all of that.
And then we're going to have
another five right here.
So this is going to be
16 plus 5 or 21.
So how can we figure out how
many toothpicks we're going to
have in the 50th figure?
I mean, we could draw 50 of
them, but it's going to take
us forever.
So all we have to do is
realize the pattern.
Every one, we're just
going to add 5.
Or, we could even come up with
a formula for the nth figure.
How many toothpicks
in the nth figure?
So here, in the first figure,
we have-- you could view it
this way-- in this first figure,
we have 1 plus 5
toothpicks.
Right?
We have this 1.
You could imagine that was
always there, and then you
added 5 right there.
So that's our first term
in our sequence.
Our second term in our sequence,
what do we have?
We have 6, which is 1 plus 5.
So we have that 1 plus
5, plus another 5.
Plus this 5 right here,
plus another 5.
And then our third term in our
sequence, what do we have?
We have all of this business
that we had
in the second term.
So 1 plus 5 plus 5, and then
we have another 5.
Let me do it in green.
We have another 5.
And then, finally, in this
fourth term, what do we have?
We have-- so the fourth one-- we
have everything that we had
in the third figure, so 1
plus 5 plus 5 plus 5.
And then we add another 5.
We add a fourth 5.
We add a fourth 5 right there.
So why did I do it this way?
Because I wrote this first one
as 1 plus 5 instead of just a
6 because you could say, well
look, I had a 1, and
then I had one 5.
Now I have a 1, and
I have two 5's.
Now I have a 1 and
I have three 5's.
I have four 5's.
So you might see the pattern.
If I had the nth term, if I had
the nth term right here, I
will have a 1 plus
n 5's, right?
The first term has one 5.
The second term has two 5's.
Third term has three 5's.
Fourth term has four 5's.
So the nth term, if this is, you
know, if this is 10, it's
going to be 1 plus 10 5's.
Or if it's n, if I'm kind of
abstracting a little bit, I'm
going to have 1 plus
10-- sorry-- 1
plus 5 times n, right?
And try it out.
If n is equal 1, it's going
to be 5 times 1.
If n is equal to 2, it's
going to be 5 times 2.
If n is equal to 3, it's
going to be 5 times 3.
So that when the 50th term, if
we're talking about the 50th
term, how many toothpicks
are we going to have?
Well we're going to have 1 plus
5 times 50, right? n is
50 here, which is
equal to what?
5 times 50 is 250.
That's 250 and then we add 1,
we're going to have 251
toothpicks will be needed
to form the 50th
figure in this sequence.